Lay out your Bear Skin Picnic Blanket.
And if you spill something just use the portable
washing machine.
Because It's episode 40 of LÜT
Drift through the day with the Verrado Electric
Drift Trike.
An adult tricycle with an electric motor that
let's you drift on flat surfaces like asphalt.
Ask for a gift and receive an unbasket.
There are a variety of themes including one
for gamers, your undead friends, and for adventurous
types there's the "Sure I'll try it" unbasket.
Handrite a card to go with it without making
a mistake thanks to the VibeWrite Learning
Pen - which vibrates when you make a spelling
error.
Now go ahead and ring the Guitdoorbell.
A doorbell that strums the chord of your choice
on a miniature guitar when the door is opened.
Then take off your shoes and slide into some
Robot Slippers that make this sound.
And sip a beverage from a frosty glass.
The personal glass froster chills your glass
in seconds with the help of CO2.
Keeping things cool is the Beer Blizzard.
A convenient reusable ice cube placed at the
bottom of a coozie or as a coaster that makes
sure your refreshments stay cold.
Satisfy your appetite and curiosity by catching
a golden goose - a simple new kitchen gadget
that uses centrifugal force to scramble an
egg still inside the shell.
Or take a bite out of some Alligator jerky
and build your meal with some cooking block
utensils.
And then clean it up hands free with the itouchless
Paper Towel Dispenser.
Clean your teeth while eating dessert with
Chocolate Toothpaste form Theodent then Pizza
chair.
Burger chair.
Cupcake chair.
That cost money...chair.
This giant carrot body pillow might be necessary
to relax on this Onyx sofa made out of carbon
fiber and volcanic lava stone.
Now that you're rested use some physics and
this axe to chop wood.
Created by a Finnish designer the new type
of Axe makes chopping wood safer and easier
by acting as a lever instead of a traditional
axe which acts as a wedge.
If you're hungry errands get out the Hamburger
Laundry Basket and teach your tot to clean
before it can walk with the baby mop because
things might get a little messy when using
your at home Mouse Taxidermy Kit.
That doesn't include a mouse but does provide
an ethical list of places to source one.
Keep your power source connected and your
charger cords from getting damaged with a
Python Cord protector and keep your phone
from succumbing to gravity with and an Astronaut
Phone Stand.
All while you bring your Instagram pics to
life with the Instax Printer.
That instantly prints pocket-sized photos
from your phone onto film.
Hang up your favorites on your fridge with
a Ninja Knife Magnet
Like the pictures you'll take while flying
around the world on your Scout Carbon Fiber
Paramotor.
That conveniently drops you off at your own
personal $27,000 Pirate Ship Playhouse.
I'd love to go to Castle Murphy Bed But but
right now I have a lot on my plate.... plate.
And as always, thanks for watching!